foreign
[Music]
hey guys how's it going crystallia here
we are doing uh some shows here I got
Tucson Arizona coming up Pueblo Colorado
Colorado Springs Charlotte North
Carolina Knoxville Tennessee Little Rock
Arkansas Memphis Nashville Calgary
Edmonton Ottawa Montreal Hamilton
Pittsburgh Cleveland Detroit Orlando
Fort Myers Richmond Baltimore man this
is like 25 dates Philadelphia Reading
Pennsylvania uh go to chrislea.com to
get tickets that don't push me tour
um and other than that uh you can go get
your merch over there uh come on out to
the tour get tour exclusive merch anyway
without further Ado welcome to another
episode of congratulations
[Music]
growing or we dying that's that's my
question for you we got the grow or die
merch out there so you can rep it I've
seen it out and about I actually saw a
guy with a be born memorable shirt today
uh and he goes hey and he pointed it and
I was like oh hey what's up and he was
and he said ah look I love the shirt man
I really enjoy wearing it I was like oh
thanks so much so thanks a lot to Sam
there I ran into his name was Sam
um yeah and uh anyway chrisley.com but
you know what
um it's time for another episode and
it's lit dude oh I didn't even check the
uh
what do you call it sound plant didn't
show up but uh it is working now okay so
we're getting the buttons going and all
that stuff I uh was at uh a coffee shop
earlier today and um no not today it was
a few days ago who cares right doesn't
it what's that matter who cares
um and uh I was just getting coffee
let's see what did I do before I went I
went to go pick up oh I went to a
meeting and then I went to go pick up
uh oh yeah it was a few days ago it was
Mother's I went to go pick up Mother's
Day flowers
which by the way really great place I
forget what it was called Wildflower I
don't know but so nice the guy was so
nice
um there
well I went first of all I went to go
get the
um stuff and Kristen was texting me and
she was like is that what it's called
wild stems
it's called wild stems
that's what it is it's on Melrose or
something or Beverly I don't know it
doesn't matter it's in Hollywood
whatever
um and uh I went there and
um I parked and like a jerk I was
looking at the wrong side of the street
for some reason
like you know how Google Maps shows it
and it says you've arrived and I think
it says on the right or left but I was I
got out of the car and I was like I
don't see I
it goes from a thing to another thing
it's not here anymore and so now like I
immediately just get mad because I want
to blame somebody like
Google Maps lied or my wife gave me the
wrong address even though she didn't
because it said on the link so I'm
looking and then all of a sudden I hear
the other side of the street Chris and
I'm like great now I'm caught like I
gotta take a pic with someone like this
is me the mad and egotistical
and I'm like I don't I don't turn well
I've gotten I've trained myself to Chris
to not because in the beginning when you
get famous they go Chris and you go yeah
oh I don't know oh God hey man just want
to say and you're like oh really thank
you very much no no I but also and
you're
you know
uh so and it's nice by the way love love
the love the fact that you listen and
love the fact that there are fans out
there I that's something I have to work
on and I have worked on and now I'm way
better at it I really am and
you know I just I saw this video the
other day of like the three different
Spider-Mans
reacting to Paparazzi and at first it
showed the guy Andrew whatever his name
is and he goes like this he sees a
Paparazzi and he goes
and then I saw Tom is it Tom Holland
then it showed Tom Holland and of course
he was like
hey you know what I mean just nice to
everybody can't trust a dude like that
can't trust a dude like that
and then it showed um the other one Toby
Maguire and he you know he's notorious
for being a prick to the paparazzi and
he just goes like he's just like
so I'm trying to find out like I'm
trying to ride the Andrew Garfield wave
that's what I want to be like Andrew
Garfield
um because he was like yeah hey bud
what's up hi you know no head shaking
but anyway guy goes Chris and I look
over and he's got 900 bouquets of
flowers and I'm like great
my wife spent a g she didn't you know
plus also
I was we had to get it for my mom and
for my aunt for my weekend anytime
there's a mother around if I've known a
mother for more than a week we're
getting them bouquets for Mother's Day
my wife just wants to be so nice to
everybody she's just like well we did
meet those people at you know the park
and they you know they said they were
big fans let's send them let's send him
a fruit basket
for Mother's Day I'm like they don't
even have kids well
um
yeah my wife any you know it doesn't
matter what the holiday is she'll make
it I think sometimes she even makes it
up
she's just like it's trees day send we
have to send people a plant
okay
um
so
so I you know so I
so we I look over he's got 100 bouquets
of flowers and he's running across the
street
and and it's one of those situations
where I want to be nice and I'm like wow
this guy's showing it looked as soon as
I saw him he was a Tom Holland type I'm
like oh this guy's the nicest guy he had
beard and long hair and he says I got I
got you stay there and I was like oh but
I I because my wife he didn't
unbeknownst to him my wife had already
texted me we actually need two more
bouquets so she already ordered them the
guy was running them out to my car and
then I was like oh man so oh thank you
so much I I opened up the door I put him
in thank you he's like thank you so much
for supporting our business nicest guy
in the world wild stems nicest business
and they did beautiful work by the way
but um so now I'm like thanks so much
put it in the car close the door and
then I'm in the car and the guy goes
back across the street and I'm like I
gotta get two more bouquets like this is
like
you know what I'm talking about
like I already he already came out and
did the nice thing now I gotta go do the
thing that he tried to defeat
he did he tried to be nice to me that I
didn't have to cross the street and go
into the store
all of his thing was for naught you know
oh
it's like the end of a movie that like
you know
Matt Damon is in that you're like oh it
was all for oh or even better Casey
Affleck oh it was all for nothing oh
so now I gotta go in and get two extra
small bouquets because we forgot about
someone else who was a mug two other
mothers
and so I go in and I said actually I
need two more uh little bouquets can you
do you think it could handle that and I
said sure and he said oh sure system
right there
so I'm you know I'm waiting
and I'm chilling and I'm looking out and
it's like there's I guess there's like
some sort of Arts District where I had
no idea like there were like there was
like a museum and then another Museum
and I'm like where am I had no idea
where I was
but then he gives us two bouquets that
were even smaller than the uh
other bouquets that we got we got three
bouquets and two bouquets and the two
bouquets with a small one the two
bouquets
cost an arm and a leg so I don't even
know it's a big case I'm like dude I got
home I'm like don't tell me how much the
big bouquets were I'd rather not know
dude I don't want to know
when somebody tells me how much
something costs that I gotta pay if I
don't want to know I got a business
manager and I got a wife okay I got
those two people keeping it in check I
don't know how much my wife is keeping
it in check but I definitely know my
business managers keeping that in check
so
anyway
trials and tribulations my babies
so
I then I went to get to the coffee I was
like I'm getting you know what I want
I'm such an idiot dude I went to and I
went to a meeting a recovery meeting and
then I went to go get the bouquets so I
get to do something for me now
so I go I get a cup of coffee dude you
know how we do it we sat with the iced
Americano did he actually get the ice
Americano no did it get cold brew yes
why didn't he get a four shots over ice
because he had to sit in the table and
ordered off an app so he did it he
ordered it off an app and he couldn't
pick four shots of it special because
every time he picks four sets of
espresso off an app they always mess it
up it'll either give me two shots or
give me four different espressos
over ice and then I got four cups so
what I did is I just got a copy to make
it easy here yes dude
anyway man
um
so
I got the the cold brew instead and I'm
sitting there just loving it and I
ordered also a warm [__]
rice bowl with chicken oh I wasn't even
hungry but I knew I had to eat something
right and I had a Mother's Day dinner a
little bit later so I know I had to eat
something to just kind of wet my
appetite do you when you're not hungry I
do sometimes because my mom always used
to say I eat or you're gonna get sick
yeah it affected me so
now I eat sometimes when I'm not hungry
because I think like it was already two
and I was like I'm not hungry I guess
I'm just gonna what about what I do just
give up do I not eat today like what's
the deal do I just wait till tomorrow
you know because then I'm like well
Calvin doesn't eat and sometimes I'm
like you gotta eat and then I'm like
well am I doing what my mom did so now
when are you supposed to eat I don't
know man people do the intermittent fast
and they don't eat for like 15 hours or
some [__] they have like they eat in
like a four hour window they just Gorge
anyway dude
so I'm eating the warm bowl with the
it's fine it's okay I'm not really that
hungry I'm drinking a thing and all of a
sudden this dude comes by
with like one first of all he's got
what do you call it the [__] selfie
stick which is
go
away
you know what I'm talking about
like remember when everyone was getting
them and then but then okay it was
annoying but how about that there's
still people that have those
and use them and they are an Asian
you want to talk about for some reason
if you see an Asian with any sort of
electron electronic or fashion you kind
of just give them a pass you're like
you're gonna oh well you know they're
[__] they're from way far away so
really it's almost like they they're on
like like any place that's really far
away
like Mexico no Canada absolutely not
you you know London no a little bit if
you meet somebody like oh no that's a
cow and he's got like orange goggles on
you're like okay
but Japan India Asia Russia you know I'm
talking about you see a Russian dude
with like a just like a big like Tommy
Hilfiger cape on and you're like I don't
know I guess they wear those over there
it gets cold
but like or or a Japanese guy with like
all leather and a leather hat with a
leather horn on it and he's got like
Google Glasses and you say you know I I
don't know I guess
he's really small and thin and wavy like
what else is he gonna do
but dude I straight up just saw a
Mexican dude with a selfie stick like
that's crazy to me
to see a Mexican dude with a selfie
stick just like a portly dude
and he wasn't even doing it like this
like
he was just walking down the street like
you ever see someone walking on the
street and you're like where's your car
though
I'm talking about like did you park and
you're and walking or like well he
wasn't shopping just dude walking around
with the selfie stick and I'm sure he
was from La like it wasn't a tourist
thing
so he was walking around with a selfie
stick
and this is the worst part okay well
actually there's two worst Parts he was
holding it on his belly so it was like
resting on his belly poking out from his
belly like a piece of lazy [__] okay and
and sauntering around the only Mexican
dude with a a [__] selfie stick
within a 50 mile race radius and we're
in La so Mexican dudes are a plenty
and he's just holding it chilling it all
with it on his pot belly
and this is the worst part one of the
other worst parts
the camera was facing outward so he's
not even doing what a selfie stick is
supposed to be used for it's called the
selfie stick because it's supposed to be
shooting you
I thought maybe he had a [__] you
know some stupid internet show where
he's just like lol you know hey welcome
dog this is [__]
you know
Melrose weekly we going on Melrose and
see what the [__] guys Chomps buying
on [__] Mother's Day dog
got five bouquets man try to [__] act
like he didn't get five okay man got for
three bouquets I have to go in anyway
man anyway what's your name you know
so so he's it's a point outwards and uh
and and he doesn't see me and and he
doesn't see me and I'm like okay well he
doesn't see me so that's good but now
I'm gauging is the guy gonna recognize
me or not because if if he recognizes me
um cooked right because it's just going
to be on me okay
so I'm just kind of drinking my [__] to
myself right because also the other time
when someone's videoing me I can't be
like don't video me
because then people are gonna be like oh
crystalline was a piece of [__]
he yelled at someone that's assault
right
and so
he doesn't see me but what he is doing
is
recording a [__] two a couple and
another woman are together it's like a
third wheel thing there's a couple and
then another woman
and he's just like this he's just like
this drinking something just like this
selfie stick extended [__] ass selfies
imagine going like this
so he's doing it and it's like a minute
passes and the the one of the ladies
takes the menu
and she's just like kind of blocking it
and then other guys doing it like this
and they're not saying anything I want
to say something because you know me
dude Johnny confrontation right but I'm
also like it's on video
could be live all of a sudden crystalia
you know
so and he's also not shooting me but in
a way I want to be like a you know
because I've been watching that show
Titan from HBO Max and I'm like dude I'm
kind of like that a superhero so I kind
of want to save these people right like
I'm a little bit like Nightwing in a way
so I'm like okay
so I don't say anything and then the
lady
from the thing from that's getting
recorded looks at me at laughing like
what's this guy doing and when she does
that
he swings it over to me
lady
know the game
okay hey lady
I'm not a part of this
now he got me involved so now
best now God deal with this crazy dude
okay
swings it over to me
now he's filming me
and I get up
and walk over to him because Johnny
confrontation baby
but he's still recording he backs up a
little bit like what's this guy gonna do
still recording and I like sidestep and
I look at his screen on his phone
because I'm like I want to know a
hundred percent if he's recording sure
enough he's recording and he looks at me
and says hey bro what's your problem
dude when I tell you
just he just the my blood just
immediately
ding it's done kurdlin okay my inside my
body blood in my veins curdling dude I
want it to be like oh dude
congratulations man you made my blood
curdle that's so awesome for you dude
but I didn't say [__] because I don't
want him to record me so I just leave
and I left coffee early and he [__]
won I guess he won dude yay dude thank
you for winning you know what man this
is the [__] God damn it [__] the the
the it's the thing with the because we
gotta here's the thing that guy
deserves
to get leveled all right
he deserves to get smacked in his lip
whoops said it
but he does the guy deserves to get a
nice [__] Tom Hanks Pap or a what was
the or the Burt Reynolds slap that's
what he deserves to get just a nice Burt
Reynolds Pat writing his hey well that's
what you get right instead he deserves a
nice Burt Reynolds 80s pop right in his
lip to where not not too much damage but
where he just goes like did I did
something and it's and then he wakes up
the next day and it's actually fine
you know like that's what he deserves oh
[__] did he [__] and then no
this is the thing man so now because he
can put it online so everyone's gotta be
on their best goddamn Behavior even if
somebody's being a [__] right
and then part of me is like should I
tell the establishment but I'm not a
[__] tattletail I deal with my [__]
on my lonely
I deal with my [__] by my lonely
everybody knows about Delia Delia who's
that the guy who deals with his [__] by
his lonely okay fine yeah all right well
then he's not gonna tattle I don't
tattle dude I don't [__] tattle bro
ah anyway dude I brought the bouquet of
flowers home and it was absolutely
fantastic my wife was happy and everyone
else was happy and all the mothers in my
life were happy so
happy [__] Mother's Day
dress like my son on [__] now did I
dress like my son on Mother's Day hell
yes
did I dress like my other son on
Mother's Day hell yes
did we see what my wife was gonna wear
and then all matched together hell yes
was that four delias that look exactly
the same hell yes and I'll tell you why
because that's what I do
and people go that's corny and I say
it's actually not
I Judo it
do you think it's corny I dress like my
family
Well turns out it's not corny I dress
like my family and that's actually
bitching
I can't dude
I haven't I I dress like Cal I look very
cool okay and William also had on yeah I
know his version of it right because
he's got to wear like little when you're
a baby you can dress in [__] ass [__]
right like when you're one you get
dressed up and [__] like I think Kevin
had a [__] sailor uniform like we
don't even know you can do that because
ah it's a little bit [__] you know uh
what do you call it uh
exploitative exploitive exploitative
exploitative is there an extra syllable
in there I have no idea anyway dude you
could dress them up like a penguin and
you're like oh look it's a little
penguin you don't do that to like a 20
year old oh we got him a penguin now
he's a little [__] teddy bear that's
so [__] you know but Calvin for sure
had a sailor outfit and Kristen was like
when he was young and she was like look
how cute and I was like [__] he looks
gay and it's fine but like just let him
decide that later not at one
right
because I don't want to be one of these
parents that's like you can be whatever
you want you sh you know I used to I
knew I used to know this woman that was
like his son her son was uh mate she
made it she convinced him he was a
female
because she was like
so woke and she was like are you sure
you don't want the dress the dress is
nice
and the baby's like but I'm supposed to
wear it and she's like well it is if you
want to live in the constructive Society
sure but if you want to think do we
think on our own
and it's like
yeah
so now my grow my son grows up to be a
[__] sailor I'm pissed
or a teddy bear
um
I used it when I was a kid I wanted to
grow up to be my my brother would say I
want to grow up and be a cowboy and I
was like you can't grow up to be a
cowboy you have to actually be something
that exists and then my mom said what do
you want to be when you grow up and I
said a werewolf like legit I thought
like you couldn't be a cowboy but you
could be a werewolf that's the truth I
don't know what the [__] is wrong with
me but
is what it is right
happy freaking Mother's Day then we did
Mother's Day so that was the Saturday
and then the Mother's Day Mother's Day
woke up my wife went to go get her hair
blown out because I was like what do you
want to do for Mother's Day we could do
anything and she was just like yo check
this out nothing and I was like what is
this a trick right
right no I don't want anything and then
the [__] 9 p.m rolls around she's
getting into bed and she's like I just I
know I said but it's like you know
and you go I'm [__] [__] but she
was telling the truth she's like I asked
her nine times she's like I just want to
go get my hair blown out I want to get
my lashes done I just want to go out
just take care of the kids and I'm like
okay dude I'll sit at home with the kids
now
you know
I want her to be here in hell but okay
it's Mother's Day so she goes out and
does it gets her hair blown out decides
not to do the rest of the day comes back
and I'm sitting there just like [__]
foreign
so we did nothing and we just chilled
and then she was like you want to go to
the Grove and we went to the Grove was
it too crowded hey yes but it's okay
we went to the Grove we had dinner it
was absolutely nice
dude and then we came back we got
cupcakes dude what's up with that
Sprinkles Cupcakes place
The Gourmet [__] they trick you with
that Gourmet [__] first of all you can
get they have sprinkles vending machines
where you can get a cupcake from a
vending machine like like it's a [__]
like it's the Gatorade or some [__]
after workout you know it's like oh
[__] oh dude oh get me a triple
cinnamon
get me a red velvet uh [__] just
eating that ah this was a bad idea huh
man I feel I need something to drink
dude oh I gotta go home I got a
stomachache man
I think I got a little bit of cream
cheese on my [__] I don't unders
cream you know what cream cheese belongs
on Bagels that's it there I said it dude
I'll dye that I'll I'll die on that hill
I'll die on that Hill
put it with salmon get out of here dude
so Jewish
locks you know that's Simon right
ah it's locks and cream cheese out
you're not tricking no one right salmon
oh yeah just you know it's like what I'm
saying is you put it with the cream
cheese and it's a little bit different
yeah tricking anyone right that's salmon
if I cook it
if I put that on some rice where would
we eat [__] that's a [__] salmon right
no I'm just saying you know
it's locks all right okay right okay
because of the Kanye [__] fine you can
have loxby locks
but um
yeah we got the [__] uh why did I
talk start talking about salmon cream
cheese oh yeah the bagels dude I don't
like cream cheese in the dude every
other cupcake has [__] cream cheese
in it did you know that the icing and
guess who tastes it dude your boy
I taste it they go ah my wife says it's
really you can't I can do it I can
putting [__] cream cheese in the
cinnamon the triple cinnamon cupcake
dude
that's disgusting who you Guy Fieri keep
my cupcake you know what I like dude how
about this I want my cupcake dry dude I
got good taste man
foreign
I got good taste I want no cream cheese
I want a little bit of icing how about
that not even that much dude because
they cake it on at the sprinkles vending
machines places
they cake it on dude
God imagine working for sprinkles man
and you're the guy who has to load the
cupcakes in the vending machine
I just just that's your [__] job and
I'm the no knock dude I know it's hard
to get a job by the way they must stay
by but that company pays you probably
well but dude like no there's something
so [__] like I'm not dude loading
Powerade in a vending machine that's a
that's a nice American job but you're
the guy who brings [__] cupcakes to
serve to these rich [__] you know what
I mean just a 25 cupcake you're just
putting a cupcake in a in a in something
that literally should just be a Funyuns
uh
can't think of the word and I'm not even
taking the Gabapentin
slot
so that's cool that's cool I couldn't
think of the word slot
but yeah that's your job uh yeah what do
you do work for I work for sprinkles oh
really like in the store no I load the
vending machines
oh
yeah
so
anyway
[Music]
um yeah so uh we went to go do sprinkles
and we did it and uh
I don't like the Gourmet stuff though
like like uh how do you [__] up a
brownie
anything other than Duncan Hines that's
it there I said it that's it
how do you [__] up ice cream
dude Haagen-Dazs is fine that's the [__]
what's the other one with the Two Fat
Guys Ben and Jerry's that's fine that's
the [__] the second you gotta go to like
what do they got McConnell's and [__]
and it's like oh yeah but the
chocolate's actually from
boo oh but the chocolate oh yeah and the
pistachio is by the way which all
[__] house I'll House the pistachio
ice cream but if you make a gourmet dude
boo yeah but they sourced the [__] oh
what's the other one the one uh the the
the one salt and straw is that what it's
called olive oil ice cream hey
sit on that
olive oil ice cream sit on it dude
you're not tricking me Gourmet you give
me chocolate and you put [__]
sprinkles on it and that's it or none
are you a kind of piece of [__] that
puts the Swedish Fish on it
we deal with the hard hitting issues and
that's why this cult is alive [__] NPR
we talk about actual things like too
many bouquets on Mother's day and also
ice cream and cream cheese
I woke up today and I [__] sat my son
in front of the TV and I look around TV
and he's like let's watch something and
I I guess what I turned on Alf
he's geed up from the feet up any dude
he put on not only dude I was so I was
respectful about it too I didn't just
turn on some episode I put on the pilot
of Alf dude what's his stream you're
probably like oh what's his streaming on
what the [__] is that yo YouTube man
YouTube premium I put that [__] on man
the pilot of Alf is the [__] worst
thing you've ever seen
just straight up
it's so bad
dude it begins
it begins with the family
looking at the [__] elf guy
and the dad's like I found him outside
Sadies
what do we do
and then the kid is like whoa he's hairy
and then the dad says it's an Alf and I
go here we go
then of course someone else says well
what's an Alf and he says an alien life
form and I say Even Calvin goes like
this here we go
and then his son says it's heavy and
hairy and then Alf says Hey guys or some
[__] and then the kid's like it's heavy
and hairy and it can talk and the
crowd's like and I'm just like Jesus
Christ and then Alpha's like can I eat
your cat this is all in the first four
minutes
and then they say no but you can stay
here for the night hey you got kids
they're letting the elf go in the fridge
and give the kid beer
and then they're like oh it's the 80s
dude
I think should get canceled dude I'll
tell you what Alf
it would never be made nowadays first of
all well first and foremost because it
sucked but second of all because of it's
just not right
it's probably cultural appropriation or
something like that but dude Alpha is so
bad and then the [__] dad from Alf
uh
uh I'm like who is this guy you know
he's probably some like dope theater
actor that like got this role and then
got when he got this role
he like [__] hated everyone you know
what I'm talking about man man that's so
awesome living that kind of a life being
like a really well respected theater guy
that won't even touch Broadway because
he's like [__] that I do Off-Broadway
Black Box [__] and I only play roles of
like uh like uh of like hard-working
Blue Collar men plays from like 1940
with and I only and I wear a wife beater
in in every every play no matter what I
even if it's cold
even if it takes place in the winter
and every mom every time there's like
some monologue where he's like you know
I used to play tennis when I was a kid
and then it starts and it's like about
abuse when he was a child and
and uh and then get and then so anyway I
don't know what [__] I'm making this
up about the guy from Alf but then he
got
he's in Alf now and so this is an
imaginary thing that I'm making up for
[__] sake but he it was an Alf
the guy that
the guy that I'm making up the thing
about how he was on Off Broadway Black
Box only play things were white beaters
and played from the 1940s
that imaginary part is actually the real
part is I'm making it up about a guy
that was actually an Alf for [__]
five six years I don't know there were
99 episodes of Alf which is like just do
100 for [__] sake you know and um
it was so bad and then I Googled the
[__] dad because I'm like who is this
guy who are any of these guys you know
the kid and now probably grew up and
died of HIV you know I'm talking about
like that I don't I don't know but like
you know somebody in that show died from
HIV right
there's no way you could be on a hit
show in the 80s and grow up and not die
from HIV not one person
like starts getting Hutch that guy did I
think
Mr Belvedere probably did
uh so
look at this right is that the dad right
also had a stage career in 1968 appeared
in the original production of the Great
White Hope at The Arena Stage oh this is
hilarious he appeared on Broadway in
Ivanov which garnered him a Tony
nomination dude I played sir Andrew in
12th night at the at the Lincoln Center
bro he's sick with it isn't he knows
what he's look at this
he knows I know faces dude when I see
[__] I know faces I get it one time I
was at the Grove actually with one of my
ex-girlfriends a long time ago and I
said look at that guy over there what do
you think about that guy and she says I
don't know what do you think about that
guy I said I guarantee he makes his own
furniture and she says get the [__] out
of here what do you mean that's so silly
and I said why don't you what she got
balls not actual balls but she was like
she had Gusto she was like why don't you
go ask him and she [__] walked over
them sat down and starts talking I
couldn't hear him he was near the
fountain and she looks over me she goes
like this
and I said what and she walks over and
she said he actually does make furniture
and I go dude I know faces
I'm good like that I got it nice I'm
nice with it
yeah I knew that
I also had 99 episodes that was actually
something I knew and so anyway this Dad
I I look him up uh
or I look up Alf the show and this
headline reads something about how this
guy
that guy right whatever his name is
um
the tabloids were like
just ruining him in like when he Brave
before he died he was in his 70s
and I felt so bad dude it was like
Wright is now a shell of himself and he
really hit a low point and he's a piece
of [__] it was like said the media
sucked even back then you know what I
mean this was what 10 years ago I don't
know but um
and then the guy and they were like he
he's he's reportedly been like smoking
crack in a basement somewhere in a crack
house and like off and like pays dudes a
a hundred dollars to [__] him like male
prostitutes and I'm like bro
that's my [__]
you know what I'm talking about
here's a hundred thanks sir hey are you
the guy from
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hi sir here's a hundred dollars hey
thank you very much turn around all
right hey wait a second are you from
word
hahaha
dude hell yeah the guy from Alf
Alf
um just a montage of different dudes
there we go
that's creepy tell me more about that
um
that's my [__] paying dudes a
hundred dollars to
you know
being a male crack guy is
pretty legit I don't know I feel but I
felt so bad for the guy because he
obviously suffers from addiction and
then I realized and then I saw them
there's a movie permanent midnight that
like is based on the guy who apparently
create like wrote for Alpha and would
like do like Coke Benders for like weeks
and just write jokes on all day for Alf
and it's like and then it was a hit so
it was you know
but then I'm like man this guy was on
Benders for and wouldn't sleep for weeks
and [__] write jokes I was like maybe
get some rest these jokes suck
and they made that movie permanent
midnight where Bruce Brent Ben Stiller
uh
what do you call it played the guy
but I wish they made the [__] movie
about the dad from Alf
God
poor guy addiction is real man
addiction is man
that's why I can't start doing drugs if
I start doing drugs holy [__] [__]
man I swear I snort one
I snort one line of coke and it's just
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30
days
[Music]
that's so disgusting you know
um
whatever
how could you how could you not have a
crack addiction if you were in a show in
the 80s and 90s about a [__] in Alf
and not
uh
I bet that set was crazy dude
the puppet's the star you know
the puppets the star why did also Alf
had a Brooklyn accent you know eh dumb
we went to see Mario did I talk about
that on the podcast yet my son and I
we're an hour in and he goes like this
is it over yet
all right let's go pack it up he said
can I bring my Sprite I said sure
and now now my son walks around and says
Mario
he says Mario because we got a magnet
got it we got magnets
he loves those magnets they're too small
um
here's the [__] this is what I was
talking about the olive oil
Starbucks new olive oil coffee is
allegedly making people poop a whole lot
I mean the fact that they put the word
hole in it
a whole lot
this is from self.com
lots of us depend as if you need to [__]
more when you drink coffee
yeah put put
once you put uh olive oil and Ex-Lax in
it that'll be good
they just call your name Chris and you
just [__] right there oh God I'm sorry I
gotta I don't know what it is but
lots of us depend on coffee in morning
as morning pick me up but some folks in
social media reporting Starbucks do
product line is waking up their body's a
little too much I mean no [__] dude
olive oil
sweet and Lush favor velvety smooth but
it turns out that it might be a little
too smooth after the drinks launched
some people who tried to after the
drinks launched people's anus is
launched
some people who tried to who tried them
took to social media describe an
unintended side effect now that's the
intended side effect dude Starbucks is
[__] with you god Starbucks is
terrible
um
while vomiting too
what's behind that to start there's a
good amount of caffeine in these
beverages for example a grande drink in
the lion ranges because it's coffee that
part isn't surprising the fat content
however is another story because the
amount of fat ranges from 17 grams to 34
grams in a single grounded cup in the uh
oh okay whatever oleado line what the
[__] is that
whatever dude
acid
plus the combination of
two Foods
hey you know if you need an article to
tell you that
olive oil coffee is going to make you
blow it out your [__] well you're an
idiot
um
remember that song blow it out your
[__] by ludicrous it's like
um I was in the uh
I was in the uh I went to go do a show
at the cafe I was there and um
I went on stage I didn't I was one of
those nights where I was like man I've
been doing a lot of Road and I was just
like I don't know maybe I'll go but then
I know some people bought tickets for me
so I was like I'll go there I love the
haha Cafe it's [__] it's so awesome
it's in North Hollywood it's like when
there's a good crowd there it's popping
dude I mean that's it's a great Comedy
Club but shout out to Jack and Terry who
own the club
um so I went in and I and I and I and I
went to go on and by the way Lulu was
there she went on
um and I didn't know she went on
um I didn't know she was gonna be on the
show Lulu I bring her on the road she's
fantastic and uh I get there and my
buddy's texting me Lulu's crushing and
I'm like great I gotta [__] go after
because when everyone's crushing all
night in La it's way hard to show
then I go there and preacher Lawson goes
on and I don't see him but I know he
crushes because he's great
and my buddy's like do new material and
I'm like no I I can't dude look
everyone's crushing
and um and then Darren Carter goes up
who like
brings a flashlight on stage and does
audience suggestions I mean this guy the
audience eats him up okay he's named it
he calls himself Darren Carter the party
starter and he boy does he dude
and he [__] levels this room and I'm
like I'm not going dude I don't even
want to go up
and they're like go up and they're like
do new material I'm like new material
this [__] has been this is a [__] bar
mitzvah
so I go up on stage
people clap you know and I clap a little
too long whatever your boy hops on
I'm happy and I go up and I [__]
start to do well like I do a few silly
jokes I make fun of a guy in the front
row and I go oh [__] ho ho
hey boys right where he needs to be
and then I dip in a new material dude I
did about 15 minutes of new material
which by the way I didn't write I have
no idea just kind of stories in my head
that I maybe wanted to tell and a holy
[__] bro
I I I actually like I killed and I'm
like [__] man I should have recorded
this I'll remember it
and there's one part where I say
something
about Jeremy Renner as a joke a side
joke
and it gets a big laugh and I'm like God
that's [__] weird I didn't think that
that part was a particularly that funny
and I I didn't think about saying I just
said it after I get off the stage
my friend is like hey Jeremy renner's
family is here and I go and I was like
get the [__] out I said the thing about
the and they're like I know it's like I
I don't this is the first time I've done
the joke I have no idea and I met them
and they were so nice dude and they were
so cool and we wrapped for a bit and uh
so shout out to his family
um
but they were great I just thought it
was so funny because they know obviously
I talk about them on the podcast I'm a
big fan of Jeremy Renner and uh they had
seen me in Irvine a year or two ago and
um it was just kind of funny it was one
it's also here's the other thing too
that day I felt like utter [__] the
whole day like utter [__] I did not want
to go on stage I wanted to just be home
I was just in my feelings you know you
get like that
and I went and I was not feeling it and
then I was like looking for every
opportunity you got one shot one
opportunity
to get out of the situation you got one
time to make an excuse a better be gone
um
and I was like maybe I won't go up and I
just made my feet walk on stage and I
[__] had a great and it turned it all
around dude
feelings are only a a a moment you know
what I'm talking about
I don't mean to get all
but feelings are only are only a little
bit you can deal with this [__] let me
get real for a second you can deal with
this [__]
because moments keep happening and soon
you're out of the one that you don't
want to be in and it also sometimes
you're in a fantastic moment and then it
ends
but whatever
it's like it's not going to stop [__]
Martha Stewart from being on the cover
of swimsuit [__] Illustrated Sports
suit swimsuit Illustrated does anybody
[__] read magazines anymore like this
is so weird it's so weird Martha Stewart
is on Sports Illustrated swimsuit issue
but God bless her man whatever you know
what she did her time in jail and it's
all good
she did her time in jail and it's all
good
and now she's on the cover Sports
Illustrated swimsuit
um it would be great if she was in like
a [__] really skimpy suit just that's
all out and [__] you know holding a pie
just so shitty
but she did I bet that lit up the
internet some people can do no wrong
right
isn't it crazy
isn't it [__] nuts just Martha
Stewart just to prison for stealing what
did she go to
for what
what is it insider trading just [__]
going to jail and everyone's like ah
celebrator Ezra Miller I just saw a
video where Ezra Miller is on video
choking out a female fan and throwing
her on the ground and everyone's like
yeah but I want to see Michael Keaton
Michael Keaton be Batman again
it's like dude it's crazy bro
world's mixed up huh globally renowned
business when Martha Stewart made
supports Illustrated swimsuits history
Monday as the 81 year old was revealed
as the oldest cover model in publication
history dude 81.
That's crazy dude
honestly she looks really good on the
cover
that's I I'm assuming that's probably
pretty airbrush not because of her age
just because of how it usually
everything's airbrushed
she looks great
she's actually she's hot huh 81 this has
to be airbrushed
I'd smash
is that okay to say that nowadays I'd
smash
um
I'd smash beautifully
that's what I mean to say
right smash oh wow I'd smash beautifully
all due respect I'd smash
good for her
uh attacker who allegedly robbed the man
at gunpoint gets caught after staying at
crime scene to eat victims Fried Chicken
now I'm not gonna
look I understand
the times and I get I get
we shouldn't be
Prejudice and racist but
at some point
you just gotta be like
we know what we know what
we know the race of the guy who did it
right I'm just right like I'm just
saying like look
and I am not saying
because you know there's that whole meme
where it's like there was making fun of
how there was a meme I was reading about
making fun of how
black people steal and I'm just like
that's not cool bro that ain't cool man
I laughed and then I was like that's not
cool I left really hard about the mean
the moon was really funny I go I laugh
and I'm like that ain't cool and then I
sent it to one of my friends and he
laughed and I'm like yeah but we both
agree that's not cool but it was funny
but come on dude
and then
so not the thing but then to couple it
with the how he stayed for the Fried
Chicken we get it hey dude
who did it just who did it that's all
I'm saying right Trevor or Darnell right
so
look at this the way they put it a
criminal's love for fried chicken may
result in him I mean more of the love
for money and paysing him a 20 year
prison sentence James Taylor his name is
the whitest name of all time
unbelievable dude Phil Collins
Phil Collins stay for the dude James
Taylor is he the guy that huh son and I
feel rain
all my songs sound the same but ain't
the only one I never wrote a song that
didn't sound like this one
I'll sing a song later and it'll be this
one
so so James Taylor 20 was in the process
of robbing a man who had just bought a
bag of freshly Fried Chicken when asked
to hand over all his belonging victim
did so including the bag of chicken
instead of taking off at the bucket of
his bucket of ill-gotten booty I mean
you know
the suspect decided he would rather eat
the chicken right there god dude that's
so funny that he was like yo fool give
me all your [__] money and then
what's that yo that [__] smell maggot
what is that damn give me that [__] too
get the [__] out of here all right let's
get ah [__] man this [__] you know what
hold up
[__] this man this chicken be hitting
really
please show him freeze God damn I knew
this [__] was gonna get me in trouble
he should have just thrown the chicken
and see if the cops are all the black
cops run after it white cop arrests them
tackles them down damn man wish I were
all black
I'm racist I guess
um
dude um I really appreciate you guys I
can't wait dude by the time this podcast
airs I'm gonna be done with my shows in
Salt Lake City and Boise Salt Lake City
I know sold out uh don't know if Boise
will be sold out or not but uh because
it's right I'm shooting this a week
before of the time that the show
happened anyway whenever you get it but
um like And subscribe dude it helps so
much like And subscribe and also what
helps is leaving a comment in the
algorithm so we'll preach I appreciate
you and uh dude I think I'm actually
feeling good because of that magic mind
[__]
uh Magic mind I drink it with my coffee
but dude you guys uh yeah go to get the
tickets where am I gonna be here let's
look uh where am I gonna be here
I'm gonna be in uh uh uh
Pueblo Colorado Tucson
Colorado Springs Charlotte North
Carolina Knoxville Little Rock Memphis
Nashville
can't wait to play The Ryman that's
legendary I'm playing the Ryman in in
the I'm playing the rhyming in Nashville
Edmonton
Ottawa Montreal Hamilton is all sold out
Pittsburgh oh also dude go watch the
[__] uh tour Vlog that I do it's fun
as [__]
um the one from Columbus was was
probably the best one we've done it was
so fun we're on those lime scooters
Richmond Virginia Baltimore Philadelphia
reading and we're adding more
um
and I keep on saying I keep on teasing
uh Australia dates they are coming they
just are not coming yet but they are
coming so be ready all right be ready eh
you're not a mine that's it for the
episode on YouTube if you want the raw
the uncut the unedited version uh of
this podcast go to go over to our
patreon patreon.com crystallia you get
it all in its intended uh uh Manor and
also you get an extra episode a month
uh and that is uh every month so we've
also have like 27 of them now so if you
sign up today you can go listen to all
those immediately that's a lot of
content for that app so that is
patreon.com
thank you very much you guys have a good
one
[Music]